hi I'm Josh director of Toy Story
4 and this is every toy in the Toy Story
movie there are a lot of toys in the Toy
Story movies so we're just gonna cover
the toys that are credited for today
the aliens voiced by Jeff pigeon one of
our story artists to fix our they
originally from pic Pizza Planet and
they were in a claw game and that's
where Woody and Buzz came across them
[Music]
one of them from that game of just
remembering was given to SIDS dog which
is horrible
no more games Ken what did lots of do
the buzz and how do we switch him back
you can't make me talk you can't barbie
is voiced by Jodi Benson and at the
beginning of Toy Story 3 molly decides
to get rid of her and she's not taking
it very well at all and she's donated
with the rest of the toys to Sunnyside
daycare and in Toy Story 2 we have tour
guide Barbie Bobby still voiced by Jodi
Benson and when the toys are driving
around the toy store trying to find Al's
office tour guide Barbie comes flying in
lands and directs them to where they
need to go it's very funny remain seated
please
when they send others in Toy Story 4 we
added more Barbies so the gymnast Barbie
that Molly had and the two others from
her same toy line
[Music]
Gabi Gabi is surrounded by a group of
ventriloquist dummies that are her
henchman the number-one henchman is
named Benson and he doesn't have a
speaking role because he's a
ventriloquist dummy and there's no one
around to speak for him Bo Peep
voiced by the incredible Annie Potts she
was in the first two Toy Story films as
Woody's love interests when we were
gonna do Toy Story 4 we decided to bring
her back and we went back and looked at
the other two films and she's only in
about six minutes of films like she's
barely in the other movies but she is
the rock for woody woody look under your
boot don't be silly my hat is not under
my boot would you just look whenever he
had a problem he would go to her and be
frustrated and she would say look under
your boot whose name's under there
it's Andy and he cares about you so she
is kind of the the strongest character
in all these films and in number four we
get to see what happened to her why she
was not in three she was given away and
when we come meet her again she's now a
lost toy and she we get to see what that
means for her woody and for bopi there's
plenty of kids out there
can you tell me what I am the guys just
asking a question well excuse me I'm
trying to stay in character
Bonnie's toys when he comes across them
when he is taken from the Sunnyside
daycare by Bonnie and brought into the
room and he meets them and they all play
together
like an improv group they they just say
stay loose
Bonnie like you know she knows what
she's doing just just hang out and it'll
be fine
my name's buttercup you've met Baron von
shush
buttercup voiced by Jeff Garlin I love
this character it's he's a unicorn but
he is he's a salty unicorn there is no
way out just kidding George is right
over there very in line with mr. Potato
Head where he just doesn't need to take
anything from anybody and he'll tell you
that well cowboy you just jump right in
didn't ya I'm dolly dolly voiced by
incredible Bonnie Hunt dollies is the
the woody of Bonnie's room she's the
leader and she's very very funny ruled
by an evil bear who smells of
strawberries mr. Pricklepants voiced by
Tim Dalton this is a hilarious character
who for some reason thinks of himself as
a thespian just asking a question well
excuse me I'm trying to stay in
character so he's very happy to be in a
room where everybody is improving all
the time the peas in the pod these are
three little characters that are stuck
together inside this fabric pod
occasionally they get out and I think it
being a Toy Story they crawled inside
mr. potato heads by coffee shop in New
Jersey Trixie is voiced by Kristen
Schaal she's the dinosaur toy
Triceratops the same toy line that Rex
is from she's a computer whiz and so
whenever there's a something that needs
to be figured out in the Internet
she's the toy who goes to
[Music]
bullseye part of Woody's roundup he's
introduced in Toy Story 2 and he is such
a loyal loyal animal to woody the wind
bullseye there's so much emotion that
comes out of this character without
saying a single word we kind of treat
him like a dog a little bit and who's
that in terms of his animation but he is
a he's Woody's horse and he loved him so
much
[Music]
bunny voiced by the incredible Jordan
Peele carnival toy he's a carnival toy
that has been hanging in the game for
three years and he just wants to get
with a kid no matter what if you think
you can just show up and take our top
prize spot your rule dead wrong caramel
toys we realized is the worst existence
for a toy you're just hanging there and
a child wants to win you and those games
are impossible then the kid walks away
sad and you're still hanging there and
you get packed up and moved to the next
town it's the worst and so these guys
have a little bit of an edge to him and
his bunny is attached to duckie and so
these two are always hanging out there
together
[Music]
Buzz Lightyear voiced by Tim Allen he is
an amazing toy Space Ranger when he came
in and tore straight one he was the
brand new toy that every kid wanted to
get everyone to have as Tim Allen says
Buzz isn't too bright he can be kind of
kind of dim at times Star Command come
in do you read me
I don't the answer well the buzz I don't
know if he's evolved as much but he
knows what it means to be a toy now but
I think his relationship with woody
definitely has evolved over the course
these films they've become best friends
[Music]
that relationship between the two of
them is something that we knew wasn't so
important to make the fourth film even
work so it's definitely influenced
everything after the first film when it
all ends
I'll have old Buzz Lightyear to keep me
company for infinity chatter telephone
voice by Teddy Newton he's the lifer
that's been in Sunnyside forever the
only way you can talk to him kind of
like in jail is picking up the phone and
speaking directly into the receiver he
knows how to get out of Sunnyside and he
tells what he had to do it but he also
lets him know all the dangers are gonna
happen if he even tries it there's only
one way to leave this place friend him
we had the same kid chuckles the clown
voiced by Bud lucky chuckles was one of
Daisy's original toys and experienced
the whole journey of Lotso alongside
with him we're lotsa went one way and
when evil chuckles was saved by Bonnie
and fixed and that's how he ends up in
Bonnie's room how'd you get out
I got broke Bonnie found me
combat Carl is voiced by Carl Weathers
combat Carl never gives up
combat Carl finds away and except for in
the first Toy Story movie he was blown
up
[Music]
get ducky voiced by the amazing
keegan-michael key
he is kind of probably the most angry of
the two even though he's got these tiny
little legs that he complains about you
maybe say it what with these tiny legs I
cannot reach without your help
he and bunny are just hand-in-hand
literally been wanting to get with a kid
and when Buzz knocks him down and ruins
their chance they are not happy
do kaboom Canada's greatest stuntman oh
yeah do kaboom voiced by Keanu Reeves is
Canada's greatest stuntman and he's a
old friend of Beau's and when beau needs
his help they go to find him and ask for
his help
hi Duke who's the cowboy do you meet
woody the problem is that he is
completely obsessed with his old
commercial from when he was brand new
and he could never live up to what the
commercial actually could do and I think
we've all experienced that when you see
the toys toy commercial so amazing but
then the toy is kind of uh not as cool
as it was it was advertised so he has
some baggage from that now it it's a
sketch it draws to communicate with the
other toys it has fun in Twitter a one
with woody weeks has draw and it draws
draw again Toy Story 2 it's drawing out
the exhibit a Exhibit B the map of where
alph what might have gone we took woody
he's like a living PowerPoint
presentation
the evil Emperor Zurg voiced by
understanding Zhuge is Buzz Lightyear's
arch-nemesis
in Twitter 82 we also find out he's his
father and they call him play catch or
key is the wrench that we threw into the
Toy Story films
he's a arts and crafts project basically
that came to life when Bonnie played
with him and he's voiced by the amazing
Tony Hale this is for ki I'm trashed
it was just so much fun to have a
character that has never seen Toy Story
1 through 3 and and it all sudden comes
to life so he can do and say anything
and not not understand why you should
fall down when a kid comes into the room
and he doesn't get any of it so he's so
much fun voiced by Tony like I said
because he's so neurotic and full of
anxiety but also innocent and hilarious
[Music]
my name is Gabi Gabi Gabi Gabi is an an
old talking toy from the same era as
woody and she's been stuck in San TKE
store for the last 60 years
she's voiced by Christina Hendricks
who's incredible the idea of Gabi is
that she has a broken voice box that is
why she's never been with a kid and when
woody comes into the store he is still
working and she is willing to take it
from him in order to get with a kid no
matter what kid toys around here don't
have kids she's definitely our villain
and she has kind of a godfather quality
to her doogle McGuiness
voiced by Ali Maki she's the tiniest toy
we've ever done in Toy Story she's
better half an inch tall but she's got
the biggest attitude and she has an
amazing laugh she's an officer of
giggling with dimples she's worked for
pet Patrol for the town of Minneapolis
woody was kidnapped ham voiced by the
amazing John Ratzenberger this is a
knowitall character that the reason that
he was a know-it-all is the idea was
he's a piggy bank so he's always up on a
shelf which means he kind of has a lay
of the land on everything happening in
the room and that's where that kind of
came about and John Ratzenberger's a
perfect voice for that because John
Ratzenberger actually knows everything
negatory
it's a fence 380 finest childproof lock
in the world and he's just always part
of the amazing chorus of background
characters that are always there to to
tell the other toys how stupid they are
we'll get ready for workshop
[Music]
Jesse the yodeling cowgirl voiced by
Joan Cusack this is one of the most fun
characters in my opinion of the Toy
Story franchise she's part of Woody's
roundup gang and woody didn't even know
that she was kind of his family that she
existed until Toy Story 2 she's so much
fun just somewhat full of energy all the
time and kinda has a thing for buzz that
we learned about in Toy Story 3 so who's
ready for Ken's dream tour Ken voiced by
Michael Keaton
he's a accessory to Barbie heck you
don't know me from GI Joe but when I
look at you I feel like we were kin is
extremely optimistic at all times even
though it's revealed he's working for
the villain when his relationship with
Barbie is putting the balance he'll
definitely choose Barbie over lots
though any day there's a hundred million
just like her not to me there's plenty
binoculars voice also by Joe ramped this
guy just has an incredible vision he's a
wind-up toy but they only use him kind
of when they need to be able to see far
distances but please call me Lotso Lotso
huggin bear voiced by Ned Beatty he's
the kind of the kingpin of Sunnyside
daycare and Ty story 3 Lotso was
abandoned by his owner Daisy years ago
and went tried to find her again goes
back to her house and really realizes
he's been replaced by another lot so
huggin Barrett which completely destroys
him and he then becomes the kingpin of
Sunnyside daycare because of that
[Music]
Lotso being in Sunnyside has a bunch of
henchmen that are right there with him
that are helping to enforce all the
rules of the world of the daycare so
that certain toys don't leave certain
rooms and he's trying to keep everybody
in balance well thank you big baby big
baby is lots OHS right hand man right
hand baby never says a word in the Toy
Story films except tougher coos and
makes raspberry noises like like a baby
I always love that the drawing on the
baby looks like prison tattoos that
always makes me laugh like bookworm is
voiced by the amazing Richard kind he
has access to all of the manuals of all
the toys in the Sunnyside daycare and so
he knows exactly how to manipulate
anybody including Buzz Lightyear I don't
know why this couldn't wait until
morning Ken but there you go he ain't
the sharpest knife in the places where
they keep the knives chunk is one of the
the henchmen and he's literally
two-faced he hits himself on the head
there's a button up there and it
switches from a happy face to an angry
face monkey is a symbol monkey that is
used as the lookout in Sunnyside daycare
he's always got his eyes on all the
video cameras video screens at all time
to see if any of the toys are moving
about and when he sees anything
happening he lets him know sparks is one
of the most creative names we ever came
up with for a character because he's a
robot and he shoots sparks streched
voiced by Whoopi Goldberg is he's like
this final gooey octopus
I remember having one of these although
I don't know why and I remember the
carpet sticking to it all the time but
she's very sticky and she uses that to
her advantage where do you think y'all
go
got a little piece of yourself didn't
you can Hey lay off twitch twitch is
this muscle-bound insects character
that's just one of those muscle toys
that everybody had mr. Potato Head
voiced by the amazing Don Rickles one of
the most sarcastic hilarious characters
in the in Toy Story you uncultured swine
I just love that any time you can cut
the mr. Potato Head and he can roll his
eyes or take his mouth out and kiss his
own butt and it's hilarious just in case
mrs. Potato Head voiced by Estelle
Harris whenever you just even see an
image of mrs. Potato Head you could just
hear her voice coming out of her
she's so opinionated and so much fun and
loving at the same time Mr shark is a
squeak toy he comes out of the box and
goes howdy howdy howdy and while he's
wearing Woody's hat and then he goes
back into the box but he just he's a
squeak he's a floppy squeeze boy
mutant toys in SIDS house so Sid took
apart all of his toys and some of his
sister's toys and put them back together
Frankenstein style and created all these
kind of mutants and at first Woody and
Buzz are terrified of them but then they
come to see that they're just toys like
anybody else that just unfortunately
have been mutilated
sorry RC RC is kind of like a lassie in
a way because even just using his words
of his engine he's able to communicate
to the other toys and they're always
going what it's a boy what is it but
he's a remote-controlled car were you
scared
Rex voiced by Wally Shawn there's a lot
of love for this character and I think
it's because he's so neurotic and kind
of anxious all the time and I think a
lot of people see the Rex in themselves
[Music]
robot voiced by jeff pigeon he helps
buzz fix his cardboard ship in Toy Story
1 Occam Sock'em robots they show up in
Toy Story 2 this is always one of the
best things about Toy Story is you're
able to take the toys that you recognize
as a kid that you played with and put
them into the film and give them a
personality these two guys are in Al's
office the toys are asking for
directions and these two just start
fighting over who they were talking to
it's a great gag and I remember seeing
the theater and bus enough recon plant
Charlie execute it sergeant the army man
voice bye charlie Urmi I love these
characters that sequence from the first
film where they're taking their their
business so serious to go down and and
check out what birthday presents are
coming in I think that just speaks so
much about Toy Story and how serious
these characters take their lives but
these guys are they also abandon their
post at the beginning toy story 3 we
don't
Andy's grown up Oh
slinky dog I don't know why for some
reason this character I just love this
character so much leaves because it's a
dog and we all played with slinkys I
don't know but voiced by the amazing
Blake Clark who's good friends with
jim Varney whose original voice I don't
know if there's any limit as far as
slinky can stretch I think he stretches
as long as we need him to for the shot
that were making yeah there are some
shots and the thing in the first film
he's stretching like 40 feet other ones
he's stretching 10 feet
the prodigal son has returned stinky
Pete the prospector voiced by Kelsey
Grammer we meet him in Toy Story 2 and
he is he's in his box it's never been
opened and he is on did on a shelf for
forever and now he's finally getting a
chance to go to Japan to be part of this
toy collection and he will not let would
he leave because the collection won't
get bought if well he's not part of it
and no hand-me-down cowboy doll is gonna
mess it up for me now and I don't want
to spoil the ending this Toy Story 2 if
you haven't seen it
[Music]
utility belt buzz this is from Toy Story
2 is a different Buzz Lightyear from the
Buzz Lightyear we know he still thinks
he's a Space Ranger and the only
difference between them is this belt so
Buzz Lightyear the one that we know sees
this does Lightyear and his kind of
can't believe how delusional he was in
the first film that's a light bulb hey
Weezy voiced by Joe ramped this is one
of greatest characters he's just been on
the Shelf in Toy Story 2 forever he's
coughing up dust his squeaker is broken
and then he gets put into a box that's
gonna go off to the yard sale which
Woody then jumps out to rescue him but
he's just a simple squeeze toy and at
the end of the movie he's has the voice
of Robert Goulet woody the cowboy voiced
by Tom Hanks well what do you know he is
the most loyal toy in the world he's
their first kid no matter what whether
it's Andy or Bonnie he's learned from
Toy Story 1 it's not necessarily
important to be the most important toy
Toy Story 2 he's learned that you're not
gonna live forever with you anymore Toy
Story 3 he is outgrown and that's the
thing that happens to every toy that he
has to deal with it was putting you in
the attic and Toy Story 4 is about what
happens after you've been given to
another kid and you've done your job and
but now it's a completely different room
different toys and it's not gonna be the
same
[Music]
and that is every toy in the Toy Story
movies you think we missed any we didn't
but let us know in the comments
[Music]
it's to infinity and beyond go to
infinity dummies it's impossible